What's this?
We're in a city now?
Hello, hello,
Ruby, Roar, Renner, Exotic, Glacio, Ninja, Zeno, Oogoo.
Oh my god, there's so... Pauls and Ruby, thank you for the song!
For Pauls and Ruby, 46 months, Pauls.
Oh my god, and you're here for the special stream too!
Hello, Static, I'm bad, Acer, who else?
Espeny, Hem, Czar, seed of the tier 3 for 28 months!
Thank you everyone!
And gifting the song!
Gosh, everyone, can we get some more Borg Knights in chat for everyone?
Let's get some little claps in chat real quick.
Everyone, Acer the Prime, thank you guys so much!
Oh my god, we haven't even started the stream technically.
Ah, hello tier!
Thank you, thank you!
Also, the alerts have been muted because we will be uploading this mod on YouTube.
So, it'll be a bit weird if music kept playing every 10 seconds.
Thank you guys!
Are you guys excited for today's stream?
Look at this neat overlay here.
Do you guys know I live in the city?
Now you do.
I live in the city.
Hi Joe, thank you for the 100 videos.
Thank you, thank you everyone!
Are you okay?
It's only 6pm, right?
Okay, because I feel like this is a special stream today.
So, for once in our lives, we're doing it for the non-degenerates out there.
The non-degenerates get to have some fun today.
Oh, I've never been so nervous before.
I usually go in being like, what am I gonna say today?
Even I don't know what I'm gonna say.
But today, today I have a plan.
I have a fucking plan.
Ina!
This stream was non-degenerates.
I just missed it.
Non-degenerate people.
Thank you everyone!
Thank you for the fucking 7 months of tier 1!
Thank you, thank you!
Can you give some more bark nights in chat?
Thank you guys!
What the fuck?
Non-degenerates, I'm out.
This is a union with the degenerates and the non-degenerates.
We are unifying the two sectors.
Today is the day.
Now you're wondering, what's that in the back?
What are those diamonds out there in the back?
Well, don't you guys know diamonds are a girl's second best friend.
Number one are the 3090s.
Number one are 3090s.
So...
That goes like... Oh, me, I'm just feeling...
Oh, Faye!
Thank you for the 3 months!
A 3-month stream!
More bark nights, more bark nights in chat.
More dark-mark nights, guys.
Thank you, everyone.
We haven't even started the actual part of the stream yet, guys.
Ah, you guys, you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I really... I've been playing this for like 1 or 2 weeks now.
And getting a 3090.
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
I couldn't put the 3090s on my overlay you see here on the spotlight because oh yeah and also they're like there they put the spotlight out being like you can rob us I'm like okay sir I'll be heading to your house in like two or three hours after the streams done.
Remember if you want me to rob your house make sure you have a spotlight shining in the sky to call for me.
Alright guys...
I don't know what the fuck that cat's doing there though.
Like go back to your owner cat.
Oh gosh.
Alright guys.
Alright.
Oh Marshall within 11 months!
Oh my god all of you thank you guys so much.
I really do appreciate more cats.
More more claps.
Cats more claps more claps for you guys.
Thank you guys for more bark nights.
More bark nights in chat.
For all the insane support.
Alright guys we already hit our level 5 high train.
What the hell guys?
Thank you thank you everyone thank you.
Alright I spent my money on a spotlight I won't have anything valuable to rob.
It's okay.
You have sentimental value items in there right?
You have pets right?
Alright guys.
Alright.
Oh shi- oh shit.
Mrs. Johnson?
Oh!
Is it my turn to present?
Uh huh.
Okay Mrs. Johnson.
Alright.
I've been called out to do my presentation now guys.
It's okay.
I have my...
It's okay guys.
I have my USB stick flash drive ready to do my presentation everyone.
Don't worry I'm gonna head over to the staff computer right now.
And plug in my USB stick flash drive.
Where I stored my presentation and my powerpoint presentation on Microsoft 2010.
Give me a sec guys let me go over there right now.
Alright.
I worked very hard on this.
I even have...
No cards ready for you guys.
I plugged in my USB stick flash drive on the staff school computer.
And I have my flash cards ready.
And I hope I get an A.
I hope Mrs. Johnson gets me... gives me an A guys.
I really do.
Alright guys.
The new girl is like...
No it's only one gigabyte but it's okay.
Alright.
Alright everyone.
I am like...
alright.
Please I worked very hard I just want you guys to know I actually worked very hard on this powerpoint.
Alright.
Here it is.
Doki Bird.
By Doki Bird.
On April 16th, 2021.
Twitch.tv slash Doki Bird.
We are here on a mission to provide a vision.
I couldn't find the English version of this, but it still means the same thing.
So... Alright, so... Guys, you guys must be all wondering... Who am I?
Who is this girl right here?
For those who don't know who I am, this is your first time on the stream.
So, my name is actually Doki, quotation, maple quotation, bird.
Ah yes, first name Doki, last name bird.
But no, no, to be fair, Doki bird is actually my thief name.
So you know how thieves don't put their real names in there?
Cause it's like, you know, that's how you get caught?
So, I'm called... My thief name is actually Doki bird, but my real name is maple, or is it?
I mean, I don't know, I have like 200 passports.
I think this is my real name.
After looking through like 200 of them, I think this is the closest one to my passport name.
It's been a while guys, it's... um...
It's been a while, so I don't really remember which one's the real one.
So I assume it's maple.
Anyway, as you guys were wondering...
What?
When's my birthday?
You guys aren't born with 5 different birthdays?
So I have 5 birthdays.
Please write this down chat.
Please write this down.
Guys, please write this down.
My first birthday is on December 15th.
My second birthday is on December 15th.
My third birthday is on October 30th.
Guys, this will be on the test later, so please remember these birthdays.
My fourth one is April 16th, which is today.
Happy birthday to me!
And then my last one is July 4th.
I still can't believe an entire country celebrates my birthday.
Isn't that crazy?
Who was born first, me or America?
Obviously me.
I'm immortal.
But then, that's not all guys.
There's more.
What do I do?
Well, if you guys did not listen earlier, please wake up.
But what do I do?
I am a thief.
I am here to rob you.
So a hat will be passed down later at the end of the presentation.
And you can put how much money you want inside.
But I would recommend putting your entire wallet and a deed to your house.
So just remember that guys.
And a con man.
Ah, Komatsu!
Thank you for the raid!
You guys, you're just in time!
Just in time.
We are learning about me.
And a hat will be passed down, down the audience.
So remember to put down all your prized possessions in the hat.
Thank you very much everyone.
Do you think this entertainment is free?
No, there's a fucking $80 entrance fee guys.
But don't worry.
I don't want to be a nuisance.
I know some of you might have forgotten.
So just put $80 in the hat.
Plus your entire wallet.
Anyway...
I'm also a cat burglar.
Like I say.
I also break into your houses.
And it doesn't matter if you want me to.
I'm still... and you leave the door open.
And I'm locked.
I'm still gonna break in.
I'm breaking several of your windows.
Because that's where the fun part lies.
Hey Remy thank you so much for 3 months and I'm 1st tier.
Thank you guys.
Thank you everyone for the subs.
And the rate and some follows.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I really do.
I have my note cards here.
So I'm having a very good meditation.
I hope Mrs. Johnson gives me an A.
Anyway...
I actually do have one final thing to do.
One final job.
Is that I am also.
Also, if you guys did not realize, I am also an artist.
Because if you're wondering why do you take money for art?
Can't you just rob people instead?
Well the thing is, I'm giving like a little restriction on how many times I can rob someone.
And I have to abide by the terms of services from various banks and museums.
And we have an agreement that I can only rob them like once a year.
So because of that, I have to do an honest living and do streaming and art.
Because you know I spend too much money on things sometimes.
And I realize, oh shit I can't rob anyone anymore because I stole from everyone already.
I have to wait for 2022 to do that.
So now I have to draw.
Isn't that unlucky?
Doesn't that suck?
I have to do honest work for money?
God damn.
Hahaha.
Sorry, don't care if you robbed us last week.
No more for the year.
That's basically it.
Every time I rob them, we sign a contract and be like, remember, can't rob us until next year.
I'm like, alright.
Hahaha.
Unfortunately, has to fall a lot most of the year.
Imagine doing honest work.
Hahaha.
Pain.
So it makes Jesus Night be getting robbed by me.
It's essentially like Christmas but not for her.
So poor fucker's gonna get robbed this time of the year.
Why did anyone get hit again by January 1?
Sorry for no swiping.
Unlucky.
Alright, so some of you guys might be wondering, who are these little rabbits?
Who are my rabbit sidekicks?
My rabbit minions?
My little, my little Rabbnions.
Well, the white one is called Bow-Bow.
And he's controlled by the white.
The right...
The white bows I have on my left head.
And then the black one is called Maymay.
So where did he come from?
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Where are you going, Cotton Eye Joe?
So, these two rabbits, as you guys can see, I stole them.
Hahaha.
I stole them from a lab.
I broke into a lab and was like, there's nothing here.
But then I saw these two cute little rabbits.
Bow-Bow and Maymay.
I called them Bow-Bow and Maymay.
They don't, they don't...
I don't know if they had names before, but it doesn't matter.
I renamed them.
So they're now known as Bow-Bow and Maymay.
We don't talk about their past names.
Hahaha.
If you rename something, it's yours forever.
So that's the rules.
Um, how many pushers do they have?
Hahaha.
I don't know if they're robots.
You know, I've never like looked inside them.
I don't know if they're robots or aliens.
Or animatronics.
Or like possessed dolls.
I don't know.
I've never like, you know, I don't know, ripped apart and see what's inside of them.
But I feel like, I feel like they have their own souls and personalities.
Who knows?
I don't know much.
I just let them do whatever they want.
Um, they sometimes they tag along.
Do they speak?
They don't know how to speak.
Sometimes they tag along with me for heists and stuff.
And on...
What did I just ask them?
Hahaha.
Those are the rules of the streets.
So, they tag along with me on various heists.
They love to cause destruction and mischiefs.
Um, maybe more than me.
I don't know.
Sometimes I come home and I see them with their own like bags of money.
And some of their own pets.
So, I don't know what they're doing.
Hahaha.
Sometimes they're on their own little adventures.
And I just let them do whatever they want.
Sometimes they tag along with me.
And help me break into various places.
And that's great.
I have a good time with them.
So, maomao...
Maomao...
Mei Mei and Bao Bao!
Nice to meet you guys.
Hahaha.
Alright.
What's next?
I don't even know...
Oh!
Okay, you guys don't know what I do.
I play PPU games.
So, we don't talk about the...
That screenshot on the far back.
We don't talk about that game anymore.
That's dead to me.
But I used to be a very good player.
And now I'm not.
Now I'm not.
Hahaha.
Now I play mostly Apex.
And I used to be a very good player there too.
But now I'm not.
So, now I'm just media average.
But, you know, sometimes I wanna flex a little.
I wanna flex my past self.
What I used to be able to do.
Now I can't do it anymore.
But that's okay.
I still have my memories.
And that's all that matters now.
I have my memories.
We did not speak of the old game.
We do not speak of it.
Anyway, I also do art.
When I have to do an honest living.
And I can't rob anyone anymore.
So, if you guys can see on the right.
I do a lot of emotes for a lot of streamers.
And those are some of my favorite ones.
Over the last year.
On 2020.
And then you see on the left.
Some of the merch that I've made.
Some of the merch I've made.
Because before Covid.
I used to go to conventions.
And sell stuff.
And meet real people.
And exchange goods and services for monetary value.
But now I just steal monetary value items.
Because I realize that's easier.
Look at all these transitions.
Oh, what's this?
Tomato.
I have a hat now.
I found my hat.
So, underneath everyone's skin suit.
Is a tomato.
And I found my hat.
I found my hat, guys.
Isn't that...
Sometimes when I take off my skin suit.
I don't know where my hat is.
I found it.
So...
So, does that mean I can...
Jack you with a pitchfork?
Alright.
What's this?
What's this over here?
Oh, my surgeon mama.
So, you guys do not know.
My very talented, very talented, very skilled.
Plastic surgeon mama.
Is Kleia.
Kleia is my surgeon mama.
I paid her lots of money to make me beautiful.
I went under the knife.
And now here I am.
That's me.
Oh, what's this?
Hey, guys.
You do not know Kleia.
She is amazing.
Look at her art.
Look at it.
Look at the beautiful art.
Look at all this.
Look at that.
And my favorite.
I bet you.
Your mom isn't as buff as my mom.
I challenge your moms.
I challenge your mom.
To a backyard fight.
Yeah.
Not everyone can say that their moms are buff as fuck.
She lifts every day.
Look at her.
My mom is cooler than your mom.
My mom could beat your mom up.
But yeah, I love her.
I love Kleia.
She made me the smug little bitch I am today.
I hope you guys are liking all these transitions.
I spent.
I legitimately spent way too much time on this powerpoint.
Selecting the best transitions for everyone.
And putting transitions on every single thing.
I feel like I'm back in school already.
I like when my mom works at Microsoft.
I can get you banned off Xbox.
I've done it without you.
Being a smug little bitch.
You're the first place.
Thank you.
I tried very hard at being the smug little bitch.
All right.
I honestly already forgot what's...
Okay.
Oh yes.
Would you guys like to know the design process I had with my mom?
So basically...
My outfit inspiration.
I've always been a thief.
But in the before four.
I realized my other outfit was very impractical.
For thieving.
So I was inspired by...
A very classic Vocaloid song.
Phantom Thieves.
Peter and Jenny.
It's a very very good song.
You guys should check it out.
And this was the very first draft that we had together.
It was between red or...
Gray?
I'm sorry.
I don't know colors very well.
I am an artist by the way.
So this was the very first draft of my outfit.
And then we got to here.
So as you see.
We were trying to decide.
Okay.
You can't see my legs right now.
But we were trying to decide accessories here.
So I had two versions at first.
You guys were like.
What are you doing with these tiny little...
These tiny little bags here.
So this is where I put all my...
Like...
Pickpocket.
Pickpocket and lock picking devices.
In those little bags.
But then I realized the third one was like.
Clea this bag is too tiny.
I can't fit anything in there.
Where do I put the snacks too?
Where do I put anything in there?
Do I put pennies in this tiny bag?
So then Clea was like.
Yeah this ain't it.
What am I going to do?
Put Cheetos in this tiny ass bag Clea?
Clea?
So...
So we were like.
So in the end.
We decided.
Clea.
Decided that this is a better option.
For my lock picking stuff.
And my snackies too.
My snack breaks.
Whenever I need to get a snack break.
I go into this pocket and pull out a Cheeto.
It also fits other stuff too.
I guess to rob you better.
But what's important are my snackies.
Only for getting nothing but Cheetos.
Now that's a nice leaky bag.
Alright.
And then we were like.
I would like more accessories please.
So Clea.
I would like some more accessories.
And I just would like you to know.
My earring.
My ear right here.
Is a clip on.
Cause I'm afraid of piercings.
So everything you see here are clip ons.
Cause I don't like needles on my body.
I'm afraid of piercings.
So I'm afraid of piercings.
It's a clip on earring.
So we were trying to figure out.
What's the best.
What are the best alternatives.
For accessories.
But the surgery.
That's a clip on too.
I can easily take my face off.
I can unclip my face off guys.
It's alright.
They're all clip ons.
So you can see all the little drafts.
We had here.
For the different types of hair accessories.
The face accessories I have here.
And yeah.
We decided to mix and match them.
So you can see that we mix and match some of the.
The little.
The clover heart.
Diamond spade.
We mixed and matched them.
I was like.
I don't think.
I think.
Why don't we try a different sort of mix and match.
And then.
Bam.
Bing bada bing bada boom.
Here we go.
There's my clip on face.
There it is.
That's my skin.
Are your hair clips clip ons too?
Yep they are.
Everything you see on my face is a clip on.
Because.
This is my skin is a clip on.
Because underneath is a tomato.
As we've learned earlier.
You guys gotta pay attention or you won't get an A on the test at the end.
You won't get an A on the test at the end.
Alright.
Anyways guys.
We're almost at the end of the presentation.
Already?
How could it be?
That fast?
But guys.
We can hit the target.
If we work together.
That was just a mandatory thing.
I had to put in the presentation.
To appease the teachers.
Alright.
The bibliography.
So.
So guys.
Are you guys wondering who did everything?
Okay.
I just want you all to know.
I spent an hour.
Researching.
How to do an MLA format.
On Twitter handles.
So.
I don't know if any of you guys had PTSD.
On great.
Marking.
From teachers.
But if you mess up.
Citations.
An MLA format.
In bibliographies.
You get a mark deduction.
For every wrong citation.
But I am a good student.
Mrs. Johnson.
I cited right.
I did the MLA format.
So.
My overlays.
Most of the overlays you see here.
Is done by.
Bunnies.
She is amazing.
I go to her for a lot of overlays.
Like the animated cities.
Over in the back.
The eyes blinking.
She did all of that.
And in my starting screen.
The animation was done by.
Miflu.
She also did the transition stingers too.
So give her a warm.
My IBD is coming back.
When a teacher.
Drills you down with MLA format.
You never forget.
My logo.
My Yogi bird logo.
Was done by Senior Mew Mew.
And he is actually a Japanese logo designer too.
But he speaks English.
So it was great.
At first I just google translated.
I google translated.
English to Japanese.
And I was like.
Can you do me a logo.
And he wrote back in English.
Because I guess he realized.
My google translated Japanese.
Was very bad.
So he was like.
We can talk in English.
And I was like thank you.
Thank you so much.
I.
Who would have thought.
I didn't even tell him I know English.
I just like.
Send him what I want.
I was like are you open for logo commissions.
And then in Japanese.
Because I just you know.
I wrote that in English.
And then google translated.
And then copy and pasted it to him.
And he wrote back in English to me.
He wrote back in English.
And was like yes I do logo commissions.
And I was like thank you.
And we can speak in English.
I was like thank you.
And the music.
The jazzy music we had here.
Was done by Nal Noor.
It was crazy.
He did most of the songs.
Um.
And like each track he did.
Was finished in a day.
Which is crazy.
He's like so talented.
And I was like.
You know what I asked for him.
I was like I want some background music.
For my character.
And I want it to be jazz.
And then bam.
Three hours later.
Here's the first draft.
I'm like what the fuck.
Okay.
It's time time for what.
It's Laura time.
We're learning so much about me.
And then my other screens.
Sorry I'm so dumb.
I'm just saying her name too.
Hoopiyon.
So Hoopiyon.
She has done a lot of my Be right back screens.
Which I will show you guys later on.
When I have to be right back.
And get ready for showing you guys the expressions.
And the animations that I have.
That Clea my mom did for me.
Um.
She did a ton of Be right back screens for me.
A lot of them.
Like the sky one.
The desert one.
I didn't recognize them.
But all of them were done by her.
And my emotes.
The non-bark knight emotes that you see.
By the way.
If you guys do not recall.
I am an emote artist.
But I am not motivated by anything but money.
So I don't draw for myself.
Because I realized.
Hey I can't pay myself.
So in the end I just pay other people to draw for me.
I pay other people to do the work for me.
Because I realized.
Hey.
I don't want to do anything for myself.
Oh my god CB.
Thank you for the gift that's up.
Thank you CB.
Can we get some more bark knights in chat for CB.
And Linking.
Linking for the prime.
Thank you.
More bark knights in chat everyone.
Let me get some claps in here.
We all know the clap.
My algorithm has learned how to clap properly now.
So I am going to do this as much as I can.
I am going to clap.
So Hachi did my emotes.
The non bark knight ones.
And the other emotes that you see there.
I did it.
I just pulled out MS Paint.
I drew a sword.
Or I took a picture of my dog.
I drew eyes on him.
I didn't even upload the original file.
I did it on stream.
And I asked my chat.
Can you guys screenshot my stream for me.
And then send it over.
And then I will upload it on Twitch.
You can see in the sub badges too.
I drew that.
I drew the sub badges.
Some of you guys might see the little cross hair.
Of my mouse on the sub badges.
Because those are just screenshots of the screen.
I am a very productive member of society.
But that's not all.
There is more.
So...
If you go to the end.
We have an outro video.
And it's the usual outro video.
I didn't change it.
It's not revamped or anything.
But that was done by Evil Desu.
And he is actually amazing.
He has done a lot of...
animated videos with motion graphics.
And stuff for people like Pokemon.
And everything.
And I saw the stuff he's done and I'm like...
here is money that I stole.
Can you do a little...
This is the one for me too.
And then, yep, he did the outro video.
And the other graphics, Hibi.
Hibi, I've gone to her many numerous times.
Like YouTube thumbnails, the video thumbnails that I want.
Some YouTube thumbnails.
Like any graphics I need, like emergency or just like something super quick done, I go to Hibi for it.
And she also does the postcards for them.
If you guys, for those of you who know about the postcards design, she did most, she did, not most, all the graphics for the postcards.
You stole?
Of course, I'm a thief!
I'm just an honest thief trying to make a living.
Of course I stole.
And then the alerts, if you guys, the alerts.
These guys have commissioned over the years.
So Insanity, Poor, and Cassies have done most of the alerts that you see here.
In terms of like follow, subscriptions, and um...
What else?
What else do people do?
Raids, hosts, like most of them all those bits, most of all those alert animations you see there, the artwork for that were done by those three.
So yeah, it's great.
Alright, so, that is actually the end of my PowerPoint.
Do I get an A, Mrs. Johnson?
I did the thing.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Oh!
Alright, Mrs. Johnson said I got a C.
But that's...
I tried to make that...
It's okay.
You failed successfully.
Hey guys, I passed!
I passed!
Everyone!
I passed, guys!
I got a C!
Woo!
To be fair, it doesn't really matter how well you do in school.
C's get degrees!
All you have to do is pass!
Jobs don't care!
If you like, if you got through school by a nice solid 70% What is passing?
A nice solid 68% It's alright!
As long as you get the degree!
Thanks, Mrs. Johnson!
Thank you!
Alright, guys!
Alright, so what's next?
You guys are wondering.
What's next?
Cause that was a very short...
That was a very short powerpoint.
What are my likes and dislikes?
What are my favorite games?
What are the music I like?
We don't need to care about that right now.
What we need to care about is look at all the things I can do with my body.
Now, I'll be right back real quick while I set that up.
Wow!
Hello everyone!
Alright, guys!
This is it!
This is what you've been waiting for!
What can... the full thing!
Alright, guys.
So I have several several amazing expressions that my surgeon mama has given me on my clip-on face.
So let me show you guys.
I'm pretty sure some of you guys might have seen them already.
Because, um...
I sort of showed them throughout my time streaming with this.
So streaming with my clip-on body.
So let me show you the first one.
The first one is the smug.
.
It is a permanent smug face.
Now, the second one.
The second expression I'll be showing you guys is the cry expression.
.
Math?
Math in my living room?
So, that's my fuck math expression.
The next one, this one is my favorite too.
I really... math is really...
This is one of my... this is another one of my favorite ones that my surgeon mama has given me.
I love food.
I love my little Cheetos in my Cheeto pocket.
Oh, and also money.
My $80 entrance fee to the stream.
Money.
Thank you everyone for paying the $80 entrance fee guys.
Thank you.
I'm sure the museum she's gonna rob.
I see Ruby is gonna redeem one of my other favorites.
Do we have to pay every time?
Every 10 seconds you gotta pay $80 to keep watching.
It's like...
You know like those pay to watch videos?
Every 10 seconds you gotta pay $80 to redeem the next 10 seconds guys.
Also another...
I don't know what my wallet is.
Ah, this one's a favorite.
So...
This is called the... this is an animation.
Called a blink animation.
I'll show you guys.
Ah!
When I'm too dumb, Chalix to do that.
I guess to make me more dumb.
I don't... I don't... that sounds very...
That seems very counterproductive.
But apparently...
But I guess Chalix do what Chalix to do.
While my wallet is...
Well, you're not...
You're not...
I mean...
You missed the presentation where I got the C.
But that's okay.
Alright, this last expression.
This very last expression that we have.
Is...
Hm...
It's...
It's not like I wanna rob you or anything.
Baka.
You think I really wanted to rob you?
Not really.
Baka.
The worst.
Alright.
So...
We have...
Two...
Three...
Three more to go.
But these ones you guys have all seen before.
You guys.
You know how much...
You only have two dollars on me at all times.
You have shoes.
I'm gonna take your shoes, Marshall.
Those are some...
Those...
Alright.
So...
We have two, three more.
All you guys know, the last three.
All three.
I don't know if you guys know the last three that we have, but the classic butthurt for every follow that you guys give me.
Have a butthurt, guys.
And then, the clapping one that I've painfully learned throughout my years being a manufactured anime girl.
My mama fed me many, many clapping algorithms and I finally learned the right way to clap.
I finally learned it, guys.
I finally learned to clap, guys.
Are you guys proud of me?
The clap immersion!
And finally, the last one.
The very last animation I have is the dance one.
And I've shown... I'm dancing.
I'm dancing.
Let's put some music on.
Alright, you guys want to see the entire...
Look at the rest of the body while I dance.
While I do a little shimmy.
So, this is the rest of the body, guys.
Guys!
Stop repeating the same ones!
I don't have it!
I don't have it enabled!
I don't know where... I don't know where my hands... my other hand are.
My clip-on hand to do that redeem.
I don't know where it is, but this is the rest of the body.
So, guys...
Anyway, I can show you guys a better...
A close-up.
A close-up of this.
So...
So here...
Here's my face.
And then...
This is Mini-Me.
Little details here.
Little details.
Little gloves.
My little gloves.
I gotta have good gloves to climb buildings and steal your cat.
And then rename your cat.
And now he's my cat.
And then this is my little Cheeto bag.
I'm sorry.
I mean...
My little lockpick.
My little lockpicking bag.
That is also...
That also substitute as a snacky bag.
And then there is my leggies.
My little boots.
My little...
Reinforced.
It's very reinforced for climbing.
So that was...
That was my entire body there.
Plus my Cheeto bag.
Plus the...
Plus the Cheeto bag.
Alright, guys.
What's next?
I'm gonna...
What's next after that?
Well chat.
There's actually some announcements coming up.
But before I do my announcements, my special announcements, let me sing you guys a little song.
I don't know how well this is gonna go out.
But I hope it's okay.
But I need to be right back real quick so I can set it up for you guys.
So give me a sec, guys, as I be right back again.
Hello, everyone.
Oh, there's my USB.
My USB 2...
1 gigabyte 2.0 flash drive.
Alright, we don't need you anymore.
I can throw you away now.
Alright, guys.
Let me...
Let me put...
Get the...
Let me get the mic real quick.
Let me get it out of my pocket.
And let me give myself some...
Some much needed...
Much needed reverb.
Reverb.
Echo.
Yeah, it also fits my mic, too.
My little...
My snacky bag.
My...
My snacky bag actually fits my mic as well.
It's a...
It's retractable.
It's a retractable mic.
You know, like magicians.
You know how magicians fit those, like...
Put his rabbits in their pockets?
That's how they do it.
Rabbits are retractable too.
Please do not test that out.
Only...
Only magician rabbits can do it.
And I appreciate you guys for watching.
I just don't own Magician Rabbits.
Anyway guys, mmm...
So, technically...
Let me turn the music off.
Um, we're gonna be doing one song.
And...
Um...
But...
Oh my gosh.
It was very hard picking the one song that I wanted to sing for you guys.
It was very hard, because I wanted it to be a good song.
That will... that will be what I want to share with you guys for the announcements.
So...
So, it was very hard picking this song.
And I feel like I'm not gonna do very well...
Uh... on this song.
Because there's like this very high note.
One for a specific line.
And I might just sing it lower.
Like, it might not fit the tune.
But that's okay.
I might need to sing it lower.
As long as... all that matters...
Is that I got a C.
That's all that matters, guys.
Alright.
So, this...
Let me just get ready.
Are you guys ready?
Are you guys... I'm singing it lower.
There's no way I'm singing the high note.
There's no way I can sing the high note for this.
Are you guys ready?
Alright, let me do one last hydration.
And then we'll do the song.
Okay.
I'm so nervous.
I'm so nervous, guys.
I'm really, really nervous.
Okay.
Today, we'll have our last conversation And drink our last cup of coffee Someday We might be 80 And think about the different things we used to say All the memories of you will just become A ghost of a smile Caught in the wind Someday The day will be the last day.
I won't forget how it feels to be loved.
To be remembered by someone as special as you.
Someday, I will drink that last cup of coffee with a smile.
So, the reason why I chose this specific song...
Let me turn off the reverb real quick.
So the very first announcement that I wanted to tell you guys...
I hope the reverb's off.
The very first announcement...
That I wanted to show you guys.
I'll be graduating on May 14.
But that means I have one month with you guys left.
So I have four weeks with all of you.
And that's why I chose this song.
It must be a surprise for all of you.
And that was why I was very, very nervous.
It wasn't because of the scuff powerpoint.
It's because I had to announce this for you all.
So you guys are...
You might be very...
Let me put the song back on.
Let's have a jazzy tune to it.
This is not a sad event, guys.
I know it's...
I mean it is a sad event.
But let's make it a happy one.
Let's make it a happy one.
What do you mean you're graduating on May 14?
What I mean is that I will be stopping all of the YouTuber activities after my final stream on May 14.
So May 14 will be my final stream.
And I will be stopping all content creations and all streaming activities then.
One...
This is the last hiatus.
Will I ever come back?
Who knows?
So what does that mean about Twitch Partner and all of that?
Because we all know I try to apply Twitch Partner like three separate times.
Well, I don't think it's fair for me to...
To reapply for Twitch Partner after this announcement.
Only because I know the people...
The extra people are going to watch me after that.
And they'll be like, She's retiring!
She's retiring!
She's leaving!
Gotta watch it!
And I feel like those numbers might not be...
Ah...
It won't be...
For me.
So I won't...
I will be...
I will be refraining from applying for Twitch Partner after that.
Um...
So this is...
But I'm not here for that.
I'm not here for Twitch Partner.
I'm here for you guys.
This is why I'm streaming an extra month for all of you too.
Because I wanna spend the last...
The last four weeks with all of you.
And end it with style.
So...
Also this is why it took me so long.
Because I had to do a real PowerPoint after the...
The scuffed PowerPoint that took me way longer than I thought it would.
The scuffed ass PowerPoint that I did took me like...
Two to three days to do.
But this also took me two to three days to make.
So please...
Please appreciate...
Please appreciate the real PowerPoint too.
There's no cool ass transition.
Just a little...
Little...
Alright.
So the next slide after this.
Boop.
So why are you leaving?
What happened?
So do you guys remember how I say...
I'm allowed to...
Rob banks and museums once a year?
So I fucked up and I robbed a bank twice.
So I read you guys the letter that the bank sent me.
Dear...
Dear Doki Bird.
The bank takes its customers promises very seriously.
On April 16th, 2021.
You and your rabbit minions have robbed the establishment.
Breaking the one heist per year agreement in our contract.
As per our terms of services.
The authorities have been contacted and will arrive at the current given address.
Listed in the records you've given us in one month's time.
If you're unsure what to do.
Please don't hesitate to contact our support team.
Regards, the bank team.
I also censored your phone number.
So we guys will call them and be like, release her now.
And then you guys must be wondering.
Why did you give them your address?
Well, they let me rob them.
So I figured this was a fair deal.
I figured...
Please update your windows and stop.
Now!
I barely know what 2 times 8 is.
Do you think I know how to update my windows?
Guys.
So...
So yeah.
I gave them my address.
Because I thought, you know.
Like, can you let me rob you?
I might as well give you my address.
And I mean...
I could...
You could just be like, why don't you move?
With what money?
I already spent all the money I used on...
I used from robbing the bank the second time.
Where do I go?
Do you know my rabbit minions are accustomed to a very, very, very expensive standard now?
They order Uber Eats every single day, guys.
Do you know that's where all the money goes?
That's where all the money is going.
They have my credit card.
I'm so sorry.
I think I'm the minion all along.
I don't know about you guys.
I think I realized I...
Maybe I'm their minion all along.
So...
So the authorities have given me a one month...
One month's time with you, all of you.
And we're gonna make it a great month.
Alright.
So now you guys are wondering...
What's in plan?
What's in store for the next four weeks?
Well then, guys.
Well then.
Ba-dum!
So, I have closed down the Curious Cat.
We will not be using Curious Cat anymore from then...
After the stream.
And I have opened a Marshmallow...
A Marshmallow account.
So it's...
It's just Jokey Bird.
And I won't be reading any of the messages.
Because these are like...
You can send them anonymously too.
So...
These will be the messages you can send me...
For me to read on my final stream.
Which will be in four weeks.
And it's just...
Marshmallow-QA.com Slash Jokey Bird.
Some of you guys must be wondering...
Can I also get my...
Also that too.
Can I also get my $80 back?
Sorry, the Rabbits already spent it on Dairy Queen.
I don't make the rules.
So...
If you guys are wondering...
But it's all in Japanese.
Miss Jokey...
Quotation...
Maple...
Bird.
Well, I'm not gonna say anything.
Well, just use Google Translate.
Just use Google Translate.
But it's just...
It's the same as function as Curious Cat.
It's like a little box there.
It will be like...
Ask any question.
And then you can write like...
I don't know...
Like a seven-page essay or whatever.
And then click submit.
And then bam.
Bada bing bada boom.
There you go.
Alright.
So what else is there?
Well, at the end of the stream...
I'll be setting up several Discord channels.
So...
B-movie script.
I don't know if the algorithm is gonna allow you to submit the B-movie script.
But the last...
So the...
After the stream, I'll be opening several Discord channels.
One of them will be karaoke suggestions.
We're gonna have...
I think like one or two karaoke nights in the four weeks.
And I'll sing some of the songs that you guys suggest for me.
So some of them will be like songs I wanna sing.
Some of them will be songs you guys want me to sing.
So...
It doesn't guarantee that I'll sing the songs.
But I'll select some of them.
So there will be like one or two days where I'll be doing karaoke nights for all of you.
And another thing will be variety.
So there must be a lot of games you guys want me to stream before I go...
Before I graduate.
And I'll also be opening a Discord server for that as well.
So you can drop down any suggestions that you want me to play before I go.
And those will be...
I'm going to play this for weeks.
Like I said, it doesn't guarantee that I'll pick them.
But we'll see.
We'll see.
Because we can't do chatting and Apex streams all the time.
So I'll stream some of the games you guys want me to play.
And then the postcards.
April and May postcards will still be in effect.
I actually got the April postcards today.
I received it like an hour before I started streaming.
So for those of you who don't know what the postcards are...
Every end of the month, the top 5 gifters get a little postcard sent from me with little goodies inside.
And so I'll still be doing the last 2 months.
But I'll be stopping the last postcard on May.
On May 14th.
Which is my final stream.
FlyChan!
Thank you so much for the raid, FlyChan!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream playing Apex!
Thank you, thank you!
So yeah, I'll show you guys the April postcard design.
I think it's after this slide.
So I'll show you guys the design for April.
And I really love it too because it's like a celebration day view postcard.
Sub games!
I will be hosting sub games!
I don't know if it will be on stream.
But I do want to spend the most I can with my community before I go.
So I will also be opening a channel for that.
For you guys to suggest some sub games.
So I guess like Apex, Jackbox, what else can we play together?
I don't know.
But whatever you guys suggest, I'll look into it.
Because I want to host like maybe like 2-3 sub game nights before I graduate.
And then movie night!
Because I'll be leaving in 4 weeks.
We usually are going to have 2 movie nights.
For those of you who don't know, we have a movie night tomorrow at 10pm PST on a Saturday.
We're going to be watching Raya, The Last Dragon.
But because we have 4 weeks left together, I'll be hosting a movie night every Saturday.
So I don't know what the other movies are going to be for the next 3 weeks.
But I hope you guys will be excited!
Because I love watching movies with all of you on every Saturday and Sunday.
It's always a good thing.
And I love to create time because I say dumb stuff.
And you guys enable me.
Shop!
Ah, Michael.
Michael, Michael, Michael.
Good timing!
So, also another reason why I have to announce this early is because I promised all of you that I will do merch.
But it would be pretty awkward if I open merch orders and then like 4 weeks later, I'm like, Hey, by the way guys, I'm leaving.
And then you all be like, but I bought your merch, you can't just leave!
So now I give you guys like, you know, you guys have some time to like decide if you want to buy merch or not.
And that's another reason why I had to announce it early.
Because I didn't want to, I didn't want to like, you know, like be like, make you buy merch and then be like, I'm leaving!
I'm leaving!
So this is alright.
I can like release the merch on the same day as I announce, as I announce my graduation day.
So, and that's why we also have 4 weeks at the end of the very end.
So after this, after May 7th, all these items, the merch for, the items for merch will never be released again.
So they are technically limited edition.
And yeah, so for the merch, for the merch, I tried very hard to price them reasonably.
Because I didn't want to make profit off you guys.
I tried to like, but I still wanted to like make sure I don't like lose too much money in general.
Because like, shipping is like really really expensive.
But it's a lot cheaper than usual merch.
It's a lot cheaper because I, I just calculated like production cost and like shipping.
And because all the items were shipped by, from me.
Like it's not from like a separate company that's doing it from, for you, for you guys.
It's, I'm shipping it myself.
And I'm contacting the manufacturers myself.
So it's very, it was like a lot much more work trying to calculate prices and everything.
Because I have to do it all myself.
And, but then, but!
I wanted to do it all myself because I wanted to include a little personal note.
So all of the orders.
And, and some little personal gifts from me to you guys.
For those who would like to purchase.
The merch and stuff.
So, I know I might lose money in the end.
Because I, I feel like I did price it like, like it might be like, I might lose money in the end.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
It's for you guys.
I did this for you guys.
And I promise the promise.
And I hope you guys think the prices are reasonable.
Because I spent like, I, I need you guys to know that I spent like 10 straight hours just figuring out prices in general.
So...
So please, I'm sorry.
Appreciate me.
Appreciate my hard work.
Yeah, shipping in Canada is very weird too.
Like it was very complicated trying to figure out the shipping and everything.
Especially when you don't have the items to like get the quotes and everything.
Um, like I had to like, I had to like ask people around.
Be like, hey you shipped like dockies before.
How much do they weigh?
You know.
I've been stealing money for so long now.
I think for the first time in my life.
I want to give back.
Is this an epiphany?
I don't know.
And the final note for this slide is the fan tag.
Um, it is the Bark Knights.
As it should be.
So you can use this tag on Twitter.
The hashtag of Bark Knights.
For like, I guess like fan.
Like anything.
If you guys want to like send something.
Like fan art or whatever.
I'll be looking through the tags.
At least, I guess everyday.
I'll be looking through the tags everyday.
And retweeting like anything.
Um, retweetable.
Can't believe you got to become weak on your old days.
Are the rabbits actually siphoning my fucking energy?
My life force?
Who knows?
Alright.
So I don't remember what the next slide is.
But let's all see together.
Let's all be surprised together.
Chat.
Ah!
April's postcard!
So this is April's postcard everyone!
So like I said earlier.
Every end of the month.
I do a postcard.
Um.
For everyone.
For the top five sub-gifters.
Uh.
In the community.
And this will be the postcard for April!
And I usually send them.
I actually got this early.
So I have.
I actually have the cards right now on me.
So I'll be shipping them at the end of the month.
For the top five sub-gifters.
And they usually include like little goodies and stuff.
And a personal.
Like a little personal touch to it.
And everything.
So yeah.
And there will be a May postcard.
But that will be a surprise.
Until I get the finished product.
It will be a surprise even for me.
Because I don't know what it looks like too.
So.
So when I get it.
I'll show it to you guys.
Don't worry.
Um.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure I have one more.
One more slide left.
Ah!
The shop!
So.
So you guys are wondering.
Huh!
What's in the shop?
Well guys.
We have.
The Doki.
The Doki Makara.
The acrylic stand.
Um.
Stickers.
And charms.
So.
I'll be opening the store.
I'll be opening the store at the end of the stream.
But it's just DokiBird.BigCardle.com.
Um.
So let me give you guys a close up of all of them for all of you.
So this is the acrylic stand.
And I don't remember what it price.
Twenty dollars.
So this is a six.
I was like.
What did I price it?
I spent so much time calculating.
But I don't even remember how much it cost.
So this is the acrylic stand.
It's double sided.
And it's the.
And then I'm doing the butthurt.
I'm doing.
Look at that.
Now there's three of us.
There's three of us.
And I'm doing.
It's a double sided.
It's a double sided acrylic stand.
And with a unique circular base in the background.
You guys always see a lot.
Now there's three of me.
Which one's the real me?
I don't even know.
Alright.
The next.
The next item I'll be showing you guys.
Are the charms.
This is also.
Um.
Oh yeah.
Of course we all know who did the acrylic stand.
My surgeon mama.
Clea.
It was very hard trying to pick out the base.
But I realized.
You know what.
We all.
I feel like the rabbit would be much more memorable though.
Than the logo.
So I chose the rabbit in the end.
Cause we spent like hours trying to fucking decide.
One tells only lies.
One only tells truths.
The third eats Cheetos.
Alright.
So the next item.
Are the.
Are the acrylic charms.
The acrylic.
It's a 2.5 double sided.
Acrylic charm.
What did I price it as?
Ah.
Eight dollars.
I had to look.
I had to look cause I don't remember.
I had to.
We all know I don't remember.
Numbers.
Whenever I see numbers.
I go.
Numbers?
Math?
Oh shit.
What?
It was Michael all along.
Oh my god.
Alright.
So yeah.
It is a double sided.
Acrylic charm.
And it's gonna come with a star collapse.
So it has a little.
It has a little.
It has a default expression.
And a smug expression.
Also the reason why this took so long to do.
Is that I had to do all the graphics for these slides too.
Like all the merch stuff and stuff.
I had to do it myself.
So.
Oh.
Okay.
Pretty cool.
Ew.
No.
But it has a smug expression.
And a default expression for all of you.
Alright.
Next up.
The next item.
Are the stickers.
Alright.
So if you guys could see.
I didn't have.
My friend and I didn't have enough time.
To finish up the last two sketches.
But they'll be done by this week.
I swear.
They'll be done by this week.
I had so many things to do.
So it was like.
So.
These are three.
They'll be three inch vinyl stickers.
So technically they're waterproof.
But I would suggest not testing.
Like you know.
Like pouring water on it every day.
To be like.
Is it really waterproof?
I would suggest not doing that.
But technically.
It is waterproof.
But not as waterproof.
As you think it is.
So please don't pour water on it every day.
If it rains.
And then you got like water on it.
It'll be fine.
But like if you like decide to be like.
Let me.
Let me take these stickers out.
On a swim.
I am not responsible for that.
So the four sticker designs are.
And they're three dollars.
A sticker.
And a ten dollar.
And if you want all four of them.
It'll be ten dollars.
So that's it.
And they're like the outfits throughout the year.
So all the stickers are.
Some of the outfits I've worn over the years.
Streaming.
So the hello hello.
Hello hello.
Boba.
The thief sticker.
And the hug sticker.
So I hope you guys will be excited when the last two stickers are finally done.
But I'll be finishing them.
They'll be finished this week.
So.
So I hope by the end of Sunday.
I'll have these done.
And then finally.
The one you've all been waiting for.
Guys.
The daki.
The doki makura.
So they'll be double sided.
Two way tri-cut.
And they're 150 centimeters x 50 centimeters.
And they were done by Daphne.
Daphne?
I have the credit on the site.
So.
It's what however you pronounce it.
But I'm bad at pronouncing stuff.
So.
Daphne?
Daphie.
So.
And this will be $55.
This will be $55.
So.
Anyway.
So those were all the.
Those were all the merchandise that I have.
And I think the rob the bank one.
The rob the bank bundle.
For all of it is like 55.
Oh not 55.
The daki is 55.
But the rob the bank bundle is like $85.
I think.
I don't know the numbers.
You'll see on the website.
And if you guys do not know.
Because I wrote it in the description.
But every purchase will come with a postcard.
So the postcards that you guys.
Like you know.
Like the monthly postcards I've done.
I have some extras.
While supplies last.
So every purchase.
No matter how small.
Like even if you just buy one sticker.
I'll just give you.
I'll send over a rob the bank.
And I'll send over a random postcard.
From the excess ones that I got.
That I have on me.
And if you buy the bundle.
You get all six postcards.
So yeah.
So every purchase will come with a postcard.
But the bundle.
You get all of them.
Because if you buy like.
The singular items.
You'll get a.
You'll get like a.
You'll get like a random.
Random postcard.
But the bundle.
Will give you all six of them.
Because we've done like.
I think we've done like.
From December.
To.
To May.
So.
But.
I think.
I think we've done like.
So yeah.
Here are all the prices again.
For all of you guys.
The prices for all of them.
Rob a big bundle.
The doki makara.
The six inch acrylic stand.
The charm.
And the stickers.
So those are all.
Should I just open the store right now?
You know what?
I'm gonna.
Turn the store on right now.
As soon as I realize where it is.
Where did I put it?
I'm gonna.
Where is the store?
Where did I put the store?
Which tab is it?
Tab.
Which one is it?
Alright.
The store.
Is.
Launched.
I've launched the store.
Woo.
So it's basically.
Big cart.
It was a doki bird.
All.
Dot com.
And I do provide.
Worthy shipping.
And that's what I'm like.
Most scared about.
And.
Same.
Thank you.
I'm not.
Making like.
Cause I'm pricing this.
Cause I don't really wanna.
I don't wanna earn money.
Like.
Earn like profit from you guys.
Um.
So.
I.
Try to.
Worldwide shipping.
I try to price it.
As reasonable as I can.
And there might.
Ah!
Yamashii!
Thank you for the eighty dollars.
Thank you for the entrance fee.
This is going.
Straight towards my.
Rabbit.
Maymay.
And baobao's.
Uber Eats.
Bill.
Thank you.
Everyone.
Thank you guys.
So.
Let me give you guys a little reminder.
I will be.
So if you guys are coming in late.
Um.
This goes back.
I.
The reason why.
This is.
So nerve wracking.
Is that.
That was the big reason.
Um.
My graduation date.
On May 14.
But.
I am not stopping my activities.
And.
As an artist.
I will keep doing.
Um.
I'll keep doing artist things.
I'll keep doing.
After May 14.
I'll still be doing like.
Art for like.
Other streamers.
Um.
Like doing emotes and stuff.
Or like graphics.
And like maybe like work on more original designs.
On artwork.
And.
And stuff on my other store.
Um.
And yeah.
But.
I will be stopping all Vtubing.
And streaming.
Uh.
Streaming stuff.
But.
I will be stopping.
After my last stream on May 14.
So.
Um.
And with that said.
Even the Discord.
Um.
I'll keep the Discord server up.
For a few days.
But I'm not sure if I'm gonna give it to my mons.
Or just uh.
Close the server down.
Um.
We'll see when.
We'll figure things out.
When the time gets there.
But my.
Like my other social media stuff.
Everything.
They'll all be there.
Um.
It's just that.
I will be stopping.
Uh.
The YouTube.
Will just be an archive.
I guess.
Hahaha.
So.
I'm gonna be doing like.
Emote commissions.
And like art stuff.
Cause Thief's gotta earn an honest living.
Cause you think I'm gonna let the.
Authorities.
You think I'm gonna let the authorities capture me?
Hahaha.
I'm gonna go into hiding.
After May 14.
I'll be in hiding.
But I'll.
I'll make sure to post some art stuff.
Cause I need a.
Fun my rabbit's Uber Eats bill.
So.
Hahaha.
I need to pay my rabbit's Uber Eats bill somehow.
So.
I'll still be taking like.
Art commissions.
You'll still be seeing me doing like artwork and stuff for other streamers.
Afterwards.
Cause I still need to fun.
Their bill.
Their like eating habits and stuff.
They've.
They're accustomed to a very high standard of living right now.
And I don't know how to stop them.
Uh.
Please send.
Hahaha.
Alright guys.
Final.
Let's do some little final notes stuff too.
Some little final notes before we go.
Before we go.
Alright guys.
Let's do a little.
I just wanna get like up and close and personal with all you guys.
A little more zoomed in.
Hahaha.
Mike.
Get back in my Cheeto pocket Mike.
So.
That was the wrong mic.
I got rid of my actual mic.
Hahaha.
Get back in my Cheeto pocket Mike.
Alright everyone.
Let's do a little.
Final notes.
Before.
Um.
Before I end stream.
I just wanna say.
Thank you guys.
Everyone.
For coming to the little.
This is.
That's why.
Have you guys.
Have you guys ever wondered why I kept calling it lore stream?
Cause I think it would be weird.
Cause I was like.
I can't call it a debut stream.
Cause I'm announcing my graduation.
Hahaha.
I was like.
I can't call it a debut stream.
It would be weird.
Cause I'll be announcing my graduation.
And that's why I was like.
Haha.
Lore stream.
Hahaha.
That's why I kept going.
Haha.
Lore stream.
Hahaha.
Thanks for.
Memories.
Doki.
Like for the actual.
Ah.
It's okay.
We have four weeks left together guys.
Save that all.
Save all that for the last stream.
Hahaha.
But.
Thank you.
Everyone.
It really does mean a lot.
I know I said this on the last stream we had.
But some of you guys might not know.
But.
You guys really did so much for me.
Um.
Without.
I got my Twitch payout a few days ago.
And I was able to.
I was able to fund my Doki Doge allergy treatment.
And I'm booking an appointment with the vets.
At the end of the month.
And finally.
I mean he'll still be allergic.
I mean he'll still be allergic to freaking chicken.
But.
Maybe this time he'll have fur again on his ears.
I don't know.
But I think he'll be allergic.
But he'll be allergic to chicken.
And.
It really does mean a lot.
Cause vet bills are so expensive.
And it was because of you guys.
I was able to afford treatment for him.
And it really.
It really.
It does mean a lot guys.
Like I might not be the biggest streamer.
I might not be like super well known.
But I love my community.
I really love you guys.
Like everyday.
Whenever I stream.
Whenever I decide to go live.
You guys cheer me up.
So much.
Like.
Even when I'm like.
I'm like, ah, do I, should I stream?
I'll be like, I'm not feeling it, I'm not feeling streaming.
And then I go live and I'm like, HA!
And then you guys cheer me up so much.
You guys really do.
It means a lot, everyone.
It really does.
Like, sometimes I get, feel so down and then my friends will be like, you should stream today!
Cause it always cheers you up.
And it really does.
It really does.
Are you not gonna stream anymore?
After May 14th will be my final stream.
I'll be streaming next four weeks.
But, uh, May 14th will be the final stream.
And that's when I'll be stopping all VTuber activities and content creation regarding streaming.
Um, but I'll still be an artist.
I still have to make an honest living somehow.
But it really does mean a lot.
But I'll be setting up the servers and stuff on the Discord server.
With like suggestions on what you guys want to see for the next four weeks.
And I hope to see you!
Guys!
Tomorrow!
On movie night!
Um, for if you guys, for the people that can make it.
For the, for the people that can make it tomorrow on 10pm PST.
We're gonna be watching Raya the Last Dragon, um, on Discord.
So I hope to see you guys.
Will you show us the ballspark before- Shh!
That's a secret!
That'll be our little secret!
We'll see on the final stream.
So that would be, I guess that would be my goodbye note for, for the stream.
Thank you all of you guys for coming.
I always, I really do appreciate it.
I really do.
Tomato Redeem will be activated.
The Tomato Redeem with RTX on will be redeemable after this stream.
The next stream will have Tomato Redeems.
So don't worry, I will take off my skin suit for you guys.
With the hat on, I found my hat.
I found my hat so I'll put that on too.
Um, but yeah.
I'll see you guys next stream.
And make sure to give some love to the stream.
And give some input on what you want to see and what you want me to sing.
And I'll see you guys next time!
Bye!